è la tutti ragazzi per questo video che
sono parigi e ci siamo solo dei
narratori sadiq che in italiano vuol
dire il narratore è un cazzo vuol dire
il narratore un cazzo non so perché
possiate fare ok cos'è sta roba mi
spiegate attimo il gioco da chi sono io
un postino coi baffi e il naso grosso
gruppi più grosso solo fare lo schivarle
lo ho capito non possa andare avanti
[Musica]
gesù ti ringrazio calmiamoci tutti tutti
allora calmi c'è la luna che cade che
cosa del corpo sono morto sei volte sono
instabili naimo che facevo niente faccio
cadrebbe bello o o no come c'è un demone
te perché c'è un no ragan macello e
questo il primo livello non ho ancora
hanno ancora non so quando anche come si
gioca
porca eva lercia bakkal aida ma perché
qual è il tuo problema a 0 ma dai mi che
come ho fatto prima
timori sul cugino madonna riga
incredibile perché non sono capace di
avere un videogioco porca [ __ ] cestino
da 12.000 anni perché raga non riesco a
fare il primo libro ma allora devi avere
dei problemi non riesco a fare il primo
lì il primo livello del primo della
prima a coach come cosa devo fare zio
spiegami già fare cade niente da fare
questo è impossibile figurare allora
dimmi tu non lo so nora gara veramente
cioè dai party di scherzi
fate i seri porca eva fate i seri si no
cosa fare
fare ciò è arrivato arrivato alla fine
[Musica]
dai che tua madre nam il
ma poi un'ora per fare sta roba da non
credere calmo se se se
per l'amor di dio c'è un check point un
check point e che azzolini è spuntata
una lama dalle balle ringrazia che non
era un dildo perché sono piaceva tua
madre dice vabbè allora non lo so la
roma fa ripartire da facciamo il video
precede famigli partire dal video
precedente che ho fatto dall altro video
non lo so io no vabbè dai ragazzi non è
impossibile
mi sono rotto il cazzo a 2 e un altro
livello il primo non si fa per primo lo
sappiamo che succede cos'è ma cos'è ci
sono delle palle che arrivano è un'amica
aspetta ma non è l'america deve essere
un fenomeno
porca eva quante sono
[Musica]
ma come faccio impugnava vena
impossibile provarla andare avanti
saltando ragazzi mi sembra un'ottima non
è vero facciamo che saltiamo anche
questa a 3 a 3 ma esiste una persona
sono vivo la ci sono le lame quindi non
ci vado io vado sulle lame ovviamente no
ok ok ok mica incredibile sono riuscito
a fare una cosa epica adesso devo andare
sul bordino sinistro non devo
raggiungere la lama poco prima
va bene anche così 6
raga cosa sta succedendo
ciò può nice ma cos'era unicorno cos'era
quella roba lì quindi è però aspetta la
gara questo è fattibile è fattibile
rispetto agli altri questo è fattibile
scherzavo no no sapete che non ci
arriverò mai più nella vita in quel
punto di nuovo vero ragazze lo sapete
voi o gesù benedetto perché ma perché ma
che gioco è questo ma il demonio
incarnato in un videogioco spiegami gesù
se vi rendete conto che non è umanamente
possibile sta roba
come faccio a schiva 118 come faccio a
schivare tutta quella merda leali ma ero
arrivato alla fine no non lo posso sì ma
non posso mai farcela
[Musica]
oggi su grazie guarda mamma guarda
lascia perdere l'ultimo libro l'ultimo
bacio non lo andato non riuscirò mai
che cos'è la merda non ce la farò mai
più atroce perfetto in che stato
incredibile ma quando riuscirò mai a
fare un livello di nuovo del genere
assurdo ma non ha mai giocato al race
game così io nella mia vita è assurdo
solamente se li mangia tutti quanti
quelli che ho fatto prima
si vabbè già fare così è difficile frigo
ragione nova raga ceva come e io mi
spieghi come umanamente dovrei riuscire
a fare sta roba
no non posso come c'è un'altra ragazza
b1 brava il b1 per capire bene se no più
tranquillo degli altri guarda e allora
si stracci sono vivo non chiedetemi come
ma va bene
no perché la moneta non va preso che
trojan alle monete che sono malvagie
pure le monete mi ammazzano un secondo
quale legge fisica dove non è questo
gioco abbia senso come tua sorella
mi fa male la mano io vi giuro su dio mi
fa male la ma è veramente assurdo non
pensate male però mi fa male la mano sul
serio cioè io veramente non ho mai
giocato nella roma come com'è possibile
ma poi non ti segna neanche cioè che ti
fa ti fa partire dal livello base non
era proprio subito c'è come ok ok ma non
vedo cosa c'è sotto figurati è tanta e
guarda all ultima poi vi giuro basta
l'ultima perché non ero morto e sono
tornato indietro che idiota
ok no perfetto
basta basta bel gioco ha spiegato molto
5stella hai fatto scelta migliore che
fare lo youtuber novità ragazzi spero
che vi sia piaciuto ho dato il
personaggio ma cos'è ma spiega ai
ragazzi comunque lo più video spero vi
sia piaciuto è stato e guarda bellissimo
bellissimo adesso vi farò un altro li
episodio sta roba ma quanto per i dio
però non adesso fatemi concludere perché
per oggi va bene così farà visto che
siamo tutti ragazzi cosa significa quel
momento nella ricca anche per i soci
siete noi ci vediamo il prossimo visto
bene ragazzi
[Musica]